history was over because the world was
converging towards societies of
democratic capitalism now in our
posthuman future mr. Fujiyama explains
why biotechnology has brought about what
he calls the recommencement of history
the new book takes on three general
areas of concern gene manipulation
neuropharmacology and life extension
during that advances in biotechnology
may end up altering human nature this
program is an hour
good evening everyone and welcome
tonight I have the pleasure of
introducing dr. Francis Fukuyama who
will speak of our posthuman future I
must confess everything I know about the
future I learned when I was growing up
from reading science fiction that my
branch of the free library but that's
not what we're not what dr. Fukuyama
will discuss with us tonight
he was born in Chicago in 1952 he
received his BA in classics from Cornell
and his PhD in political science from
Harvard he was a member of the political
science department of the RAND
Corporation from 79 to 80 then again
from 83 to 89 and from 95 to 96 he has
also served as a member of the policy
planning staff of the u.s. Department of
State first as a regular member
specializing in Middle East affairs and
then as Deputy Director for European
political military affairs later he was
a member of the US delegation to the
egyptian-israeli talks on Palestinian
autonomy dr. Fukuyama has written widely
on issues relating to questions
concerning democratization and
international political economy his
writing focuses on the role of culture
and social capital in modern economic
life and on the social consequences of
the transition into an information
economy his first book the end of
history and the last man was published
in 1991 and made the bestseller lists in
the United States France Japan and Chile
this controversial book was awarded the
Los Angeles Times Book Critics Award in
the category of current interest as well
as the Premio Capri for the Italian
Edition trust the social future and the
creation of prosperity was published in
1995 and the great disruption human
nature and the reconstitution of social
order followed in nineteen
nine today dr. Fukuyama is the Bernard
Schwartz professor of international
political economy at the Paul HC School
of Advanced International Studies at
Johns Hopkins University he is the
member of the President's Council on
bioethics and is only advisory boards
for the National Endowment for democracy
the national interest the Journal of
democracy and the new American
Foundation he as a member of the
American Political Science Association
the Council on Foreign Relations the
Pacific Council on international policy
and the Global Business Network he is
here tonight to talk with us about his
new book our posthuman future
consequences of the biotechnology
revolution ladies and gentlemen dr.
Francis Fukuyama
well thank you very much for that very
kind introduction I'm really grateful to
the Free Library for hosting me this
evening you may be wondering why someone
with my resume is writing a book about
biotechnology which is a question I've
asked myself so I thought I might begin
by explaining a bit about the origins of
this book I wrote an article back in
1989 entitled the end of history which
then became the book the end of history
and the last man this was a book about
history with a capital H that is to say
the progress of human civilization
through various stages of history and
the the thesis was that it seemed to be
directional and at the end of the 20th
century we had ended up in a situation
where the end and not not end in terms
of finish but end in terms of goal
seemed to be a set of institutions that
you know pointed in a single direction
that is to say liberal democracy in the
political sphere and market oriented
capitalism as a form of economics and
that any society that's thought to be
modern really had to adopt those kinds
of institutions if they were going to
prosper that the other major
alternatives had all fallen away by the
end of the 20th century now in my this
was of course a very controversial
hypothesis when it was first introduced
and of all of their various criticisms
that were raised the one that seemed to
me was not really answerable was one
written by a reviewer who's a review I
actually cannot find at the moment and
and whose name I cannot remember but
seem to be quite decisive which is that
you cannot see in my view my account of
history the basic driver of this
historical process was the progress of
modern natural science and the
technology that it spawned and that you
know one of the reasons that we ended up
with liberal democracy and market
oriented capitalism was that technology
in the late 20th century was actually
quite friendly to these kinds of
institutions the information technology
revolution democratized life it instead
of centralizing political control tended
to spread it out it gave ordinary people
access to
information and therefore sponsored the
kinds of political values that led to
what it were in my view fairly decent
political institutions but technology is
not necessarily friendly to you know
good political values and it could be
that we were on the cusp of a very major
wave of technological innovation that
might have different political
consequences and actually in 1999 on the
10th anniversary of that first article I
was asked by Owen Harry's the editor of
the national interest which was the
journal where I published that original
article to do a retrospective and I
started thinking about whether it might
be the case at a different form of
Technology that is to say biotechnology
would have a very different kind of
political a very different kind of
political impact in a certain sense the
reason why I think we've ended up with
liberal democracy in the 20th century
was that you had a couple hundred years
of social and political experiments by
utopian revolutionary movements that
sought to remake human societies on a
perfectly just basis by completely
restructuring the nature of society in
my view all of them failed you know
beginning with the French Revolution but
going through the Bolshevik and Chinese
and Cambodian revolutions all of these
revolutions failed for one essential
reason because they ran into this brick
wall called human nature that all of the
revolutionaries began with a model of
human nature or human behavior that was
not realistic
Marxism for example presumes that as
Marx says man is a species being that is
to say he or she has unlimited you know
Wellsprings of altruism for other human
beings at a species wide level and this
is simply not true human beings actually
prefer kin and and close friends and
they will be altruistic towards a much
smaller group of people but they will
not be altruistic towards the heroic
Vietnamese or Cuban people simply on
abstract grounds and if you abolish
private property you try to control the
family and subordinate all of those to a
gallon Aryan State it's not going to
work because people will simply not
behave in the way that you expect them
to and they tried through various very
crude technologies like agate prop and
labor camps and re-education
to get the square peg of human nature
pounded into this particular round hole
and at the end of the 20th century it
had all failed and people had largely
given up now supposing that you have a
technology that is much better than that
that is based on a scientific
understanding for example of the human
brain on a modern cognitive neuroscience
that has its disposals much more
powerful tools than labor camps and
re-education wouldn't that lead to
different possibilities for social
engineering and social control so this
was the starting point where I began
this and this is why I began thinking
about biotechnology what potential
political consequences it may have now
I'm going to talk about four pathways to
the future that I think are opened up by
the biotech revolution let me say at the
outset that I am not at all against
biotechnology it has tremendous
therapeutic promise you know with the
discovery of stem cells you have the
possibility for the first time of
regenerative medicine where you can
actually recreate tissues including you
know neurons in the brain that we had
one point thought does simply you know
could not be recreated after early
childhood you have the possibility of
curing you know many of the major
diseases cancers and heart disease a
number of other scourge --is of mankind
and I think that this I would be the
last to deny the promise of this however
I think that one of the problems with
this technology is that there are some
bad things or questionable things that
are all wrapped up in the good things
that biotechnology brings and in that
sense it's very different from nuclear
weapons the moment the first nuclear
weapon exploded in the desert in New
Mexico and Alamogordo people understood
right away that this was a very terrible
power that had been unleashed on the
world and they tried to control it then
you know very very carefully with
biotechnology I think the problems are
much more subtle and they're all mixed
up with the good things I did is going
to bring and and that's why it is much
more problematic now let me lay out
these four pathways to the future the
four of them are first a revolution in
simply our cognitive understanding of
genetic causation
the second has to do with
neuropharmacology the third has to do
with life extension and the fourth has
to do with genetic engineering most
people associate the biotech revolution
only were the last Baskar the last
pathway that is to say the ability to
actually manipulate the DNA in an embryo
that will then you know specify the the
genetic profile of the child that's
created subsequently and what I would
like to argue is that that may be the
most powerful of the technologies that
is over the horizon but that it's only
part of this revolution that is that is
unfolding and that we are actually in
the midst of so let me go over these one
at a time let's begin with a cognitive
revolution in our understanding of how
genes affect behavior there's been a of
course a 2,000 year debate over nature
versus nurture and the pendulum has
swung in very dramatic ways over the
past hundred years after Darwinism in
the late 19th century you had the rise
of a lot of genetic theories of behavior
where social status and and you know
your position in the global hierarchy
were said to be determined by your genes
this was the you know the period of
Herbert Spencer and Madison grant and
people who created a theory of what's
now called scientific racism in which
they tried to argue using scientific
language that in fact the existing
political and social hierarchies around
the world were genetically determined
and this was a period where Western
countries also passed eugenics laws in
order to weed out low IQ people and the
like this process was defeated really by
a lot of empirical research by people
like the great anthropologist Franz boas
at Columbia in the 1920s and 30s but was
really ended by Hitler because the
eugenics policies that the Nazis carried
out so discredited people and so
horrified people at you know the idea
that the genetic the genes should be so
determinative as Hitler argued that the
pendulum then swung dramatically over in
the middle of the 20th century towards
theories that that said that society and
environment were the causes of
behavior and genes had almost nothing to
do with the way that we are this is a
school if you want of social
constructionism where people are
regarded to be almost infinitely plastic
you can make whatever you want of them
through socialization and the like
someone like the behaviorist BF Skinner
thought this didn't just apply to human
beings even pigeons couldn't be made to
recognize themselves in the mirror if
you just gave them the right incentives
and so forth now what's very interesting
about the the the intellectual history
of the last 50 years is that pendulum
has swung back towards the genetic
causation side not all the way but but
an important part of the way partly as
the rise of as a result of molecular
biology where we now understand the
function of GN DNA and genes in you know
the creation of human beings but also
coming out of other fields like behavior
genetics in which there's now a
scientific way to understand the degree
of genetic causation now this
information is extremely controversial
because people basically do not want to
be told that there are genetic limits on
what they can do or that they're really
genetic causes two important aspects of
behavior if you recall in 1993 Charles
Murray and Richard Harris team published
a book called the bell curve in which
they argued first that intelligence was
largely was about 70% inherited and
secondly that black-white differences in
intelligence or measured IQ that some
important you know component of that
could be traced to two genes which of
course caused a firestorm and a lot of
charges that they were reviving
scientific racism and the light now the
truth of the matter is I think you know
the the bell curve I think was wrong on
both counts it actually led to a very
useful review within the discipline of
psychology as to what is known about
intelligence and I think the consensus
within that discipline right now would
say that in fact intelligence is
something like 40 to 50 percent in
inherited this is on the basis of these
so-called oh in it from from behavior
genetics the studies of so-called
monozygotic twins where you get two
twins from the same egg that have the
identical you know set of genes and you
put them in different environments
and you see how different their behavior
is as a result and as a result of the
statistical analysis of this kind of
study intelligence is actually not 70%
inherited more like 40 to 50 percent and
I think most people think that racial
differences are almost entirely
environmental rather than being caused
by genes nonetheless even saying that
it's 50 percent genes I think does not
sit well with a lot of people there are
other types of studies for example
linking genes to crime I mean
prima-facie it would seem obvious
there's there's got to be a genetic
causation there because the vast bulk of
all crimes in all societies and for as
long as we know historically have been
done by young men young males between
the ages of about 15 and 30 and this was
invariant across societies it would be
very you know I think very surprising if
there was not a genetic component to
this but again the attempt you know
because it's linked to race and a lot a
lot of other controversial issues it's
very hard to you know even to study this
kind of phenomenon now what's going to
happen in the future is that these kinds
of results that are currently based on
behavior genetics on these twin studies
is increasingly going to be replaced by
molecular biologists finding a direct
molecular pathway between a certain set
of genes and a certain set of
higher-order human behaviors in which we
will have a much more certain causal
knowledge of what genes cause what what
effects now this does not mean that
environment and upbringing and
socialization go away as important
factors and what we are as human beings
but it does mean that there is this this
irreducible genetic component and once
you start understanding what those
causal pathways are you open up the
possibility of then being able to
manipulate that technologically and a
lot of what we were going to find that
will come out of the life sciences not
out of some you know kind of ideological
social science but but you know I think
out of fairly hard you know disciplines
like molecular biology may tell us
things that we are not going to really
want to hear about about the nature of
genetic causation now let's move on to
the second pathway which has to do with
neuropharmacology
Freudian ISM I think has really
disappeared in in large measure as a
result of basically the rise of drugs
and the understanding of the biochemical
basis of human brain activity and of
course there's been a big revolution in
the way that mental disease is treated
through the emergence of drugs like
prozac and zoloft or paxil to treat
depression drugs like ritalin to treat
diseases like ADHD these are based on a
much more precise understanding of
neurotransmitters serotonin uh prozac
for example is a selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitor turns out that
serotonin is actually very political
kind of neurotransmitter because it is
very much related to feelings of self
esteem for example in dominance
hierarchies if you have a monkey that
wins alpha male status in in a troop of
monkeys they he will have elevated
levels of brain serotonin and that they
are able to bring about very dramatic
effects very sharp changes in
personality which get very much to our
notions of what you know identities I
mean people that were very self-effacing
or even self-destructive become you know
very self-confident as a result of
taking a selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor you also have the possibility
of social controls through drugs that
did not exist previously Ritalin I think
is a good example attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder ADHD is actually
not a disease in the sense that there's
a pathogen that causes some pathological
condition in in the brain what it is
basically is a description of a normal
distribution of behaviors and when you
get far enough out into that tail of
behaviors related to you know being able
to concentrate and sit still in you know
particularly if you're a young boy in a
in a second-grade classroom you are
diagnosed as having this condition
called ADHD and you're prescribed
ritalin the diagnostic criteria that
that doctors use is actually fairly
imprecise and it's imprecise because in
fact there's no you know clear cutoff
point when you get far enough out into
that tail at certain point you're
your behavior becomes sufficiently
disrupted that you can't function
normally
but in fact ritalin is in my view
actually over prescribed for a lot of
people who could actually be treated
through simply parents and teachers
sitting down with them and trying to
find interesting things for them to do
and you know to you know to do things
that we traditionally associated with
building character but what ritalin
gives you is in a way a medical shortcut
around that I mean I don't dispute that
there are very important therapeutic
uses of this drug but in other cases
it's simply a medical shortcut that
parents and teachers find convenient
because in fact they they're too busy or
they don't have the time to build
character in traditional ways and again
it has very interesting implications
because it comes closer than any other
drug I know to being an overt agent of
social control not in the part of the
centralized you know tyrannical state
but simply in terms of schools and
parents and and local communities trying
to shape you know the behavior now it
has moral implications because I think
again it gets at our you know ideas of
character and identity one of the
popular books written about Ritalin in
the last decade is entitled it's
nobody's fault which is to say you know
it relieves people in the certain
category where you actually could use
traditional methods of character
building but it says you know no in fact
you have this disease and the only
reason you're suffering from it is
you're not taking this drug to you know
to cure it this is only the tip of the
iceberg I think that almost everything
that people expect to have happen as a
result of genetic engineering you know
improved intelligence memory you know a
greater threshold in in being able to
endure pain you know being able to get
along without sleep almost all of these
things are going to be achieved through
new drugs that will be coming online in
the next decade much sooner than they're
going to be coming about through genetic
you know any kind of genetic
manipulation which actually I think is
is further away than than many people
believe the third pathway has to do with
life extension let me just describe the
current situation in the world now with
regard to the exam
sting advances in Public Health coupled
with changes in fertility that had been
brought on by earlier innovations
technological innovations in biomedicine
including the things like the birth
control pill as a result of falling
fertility and the fact that as a result
of prior public health measures people
are living longer the age distribution
in virtually every developed country is
shifting very dramatically according you
know countries like Germany Italy Japan
Spain are all down now at total
fertility rates that is an average
number of children per woman for
lifetime of something like 1.1 or 1.2
the replacement rate is about 2.2 to 2.3
this means that that rate that these
societies are losing over a percent of
population every year urine and year-out
they'll lose 30% of their native-born
population every generation it also
means because of longer lifespans that
in a country like Italy in the year 2050
by un-un population offices estimates
the median age is going to be close to
60 that means 60% of the population is
going to be 60 years old or older which
is a completely unprecedented you know
situation for a human society to be in
now all of this is going to be true
making no assumptions about future gains
in longevity or increases in lifespan
and I think that one of the safest
predictions you can make about what's
going to happen over the next 50 years
is that the cumulative effect of
advances in biomedicine are going to
increase you know the number of people
that live to later ages in fact although
this was controversial there are certain
molecular biologists that believe that
there's a common genetic source for
aging which in theory could be overcome
which means that you know I mean most of
the advances in health have been curing
people of diseases that then allow more
people to reach their natural lifespans
but nothing has been done thus far to
increase natural lifespans but that
might not be a limit that we need
observe in the future and you could
conceivably I mean they're people that
speculate you could have a doubling or
tripling of
life spans so you know people routinely
living into their hundred 50s or even
later now this it seems to me is a
perfect example of a biotech innovation
that is individually desirable and
rational but is going to be socially
disastrous and for a number of reasons I
mean we're already living in the middle
actually it's not as bad for us as it is
for a country like Germany or Japan but
in the midst of a very grave social
security crisis because country like
Japan is gonna go from about four active
workers for every retired person now to
two workers for every retired person in
the year 2020 and similarly you're gonna
get you know these these distributions
where it's going to be increasingly
difficult to support older populations
that's I think fairly well understood
there are political effects as well
Europe is depopulating itself it's going
to have a median age that is going to
reach up into into the 50s and 60s in
the next couple of generations and it's
at the same time surrounded by parts of
the third world whose median age is down
where it's always been through the rest
of human history meaning you know 21 22
and economically it is going to be very
difficult for societies to keep
shrinking in terms of population and so
the only solution for them is going to
be to import workers and they're going
to import workers from third world
countries that are very culturally
different from from themselves now Pat
Buchanan has written his awful book
called the death of the West where he
actually he's actually accurate in his
demographic statistics he's completely
wrong I think and what's going to happen
because he argues they ought to keep you
know somehow raise fertility for
native-born white populations and then
keep all of the third world immigrants
out that's not possible and I think that
the success of any society in this kind
of situation is going to be you know
dependent on their ability to assimilate
culturally different immigrants into you
know their native-born populations and
to manage all of the conflicts that will
result from this you already saw in
France the jean-marie Le Pen of the the
folt Nacional coming to coming in second
in the presidential French presidential
election
the flaw was blocked this guy pim
fortuyn in the netherlands that was just
assassinated there are already very
powerful backlash movements as a result
of this kind of shift in the demographic
balance and that's only going to get
worse in particularly in Western Europe
well Japan is a different case because
they simply don't allow immigrants in
which has got its own set of problems
but all of these countries are gonna
face for very basic biological reasons
are gonna face very important political
internal political problems if you think
about how our society is going to work
under conditions of dramatically
increased lifespans
you just look around our society and
notice how many age graded hierarchies
there are in corporations and
universities boards of trustees you
generally have this pattern where your
status and income rise as your age Rises
which makes sense in terms of you know
accumulating human capital and the like
but if you get into a situation where
people are routinely being healthy and
working not just as now into their 60s
and 70s but on up into their 80s and 90s
you then have this situation where you
know great grandfathers and great
grandmothers will be competing against
their great-grandchildren for the same
job those hierarchies you know that now
look like pyramids will open up into
trapezoids or even rectangles and you
will have now the prospect of
intergenerational competition of a sort
that has really never existed in human
history previously and so you'll have to
have a very dramatic social revolution
in a certain sense where people will
have to fall off of these ladders these
status ladders and start over again you
know at different stages in their lives
the other thing that I think will happen
is that progress in innovation and
adjustment to change conditions is going
to slow down dramatically
The Economist's have a saying that that
the discipline of economics progresses
one funeral at a time which is actually
true not just in economics but
unfortunately of quite a lot of other
areas of life and the reason I think is
pretty straightforward people develop
their veldt on xiong you know their
their general worldview by the time
they're about twenty-five twenty-five or
thirty
thereafter it's pretty rare to have it
change it can change in individuals but
by and large you know what shapes a
person when they are young tends to
shape their worldview thereafter this is
why politics is generational why you
know you have Tom Brokaw's greatest
generation followed by the baby boomers
followed by Generation X each of which
was shaped by a different set of life
conditions you know at the time that
they were growing up and in many
respects politics doesn't move on until
physically one generation has replaced
another generation in Russia today the
only people that vote communists are
people over the age of 65 because that
was the condition you know under which
they they grew up and so in many
respects the ability of societies to
adjust to different changing conditions
has been you know historically dependent
on the fact that one generation
naturally succeeds another and if you
interrupt that natural cycle you will
have very I think unpredictable but
potentially fairly serious consequences
on the ability of societies to adapt now
the final issue has to do with genetic
engineering per se which is where you do
to a human being what they currently do
to plants that is to say you take an
embryo and you snip out a you know a
series of genes and you replace them
with other genes the genes don't have to
come from other human beings they could
come from a jellyfish which is what they
do in certain you know types of
agricultural biology or another species
altogether now as I said this is not
done currently the hope is excuse me at
least initially that many genetically
linked diseases like Huntington's or
cystic fibrosis or sickle-cell anemia
can actually be cured that genetic
predisposition can be cured by snipping
out the particular gene that gives you
this condition and replacing it with
another at the moment the only way you
can do this is by what's called
pre-implantation genetic diagnosis where
a couple has a series of embryos and you
can screen the embryos for a particular
genetic condition and then implant the
one that has the right you know set of
genes and in fact there is the case
earlier this year where a woman with
early onset Alzheimers did that she had
her embryos screen and pick one that did
not have her
particular genetic condition and had
that implanted back in her womb so that
is something that is already happening
the actual manipulation of genes is much
further down the road now this is you
know that I think of all of these
technologies the most consequential
because once you alter a person's genome
that's it it's like giving them a
permanent tattoo that cannot be erased
and not only that it's one that is going
to be handed down to all of your
successive descendants this is the you
know these are the consequences of what
is called germline engineering and this
is what I think people associate with
with you know things in the future like
designer babies where people will be
able to pick not just you know
therapeutic results like not having
these genetically linked diseases but
being able to have kids that are more
intelligent or taller or better-looking
or whatnot
now in my view this is pretty serious
stuff when you talk about moving out of
the area of therapy into the area of
enhancement and the simple reason for
that is that in my view human rights our
notions are very notions of right and
wrong are very much linked to human
nature we assign ourselves dignity as
human beings because we possess a
certain set of characteristics as a
species like the capability for language
for a reason for moral choice the
ability to organize and interact with
each other's sociable in society a
certain gamut of emotions typically
human emotions that are the source of
our humanity and that constitute the
essence of what we regard as you know
necessary to give people dignity and
therefore political rights this is a
very fragile thing if you think about
you know Thomas Jefferson towards the
end of his life in 1824 wrote a letter
in which he said one of the we can
expect the spread of progress in these
United States because Nature has not
conspired to make certain people born
with saddles on their backs and other
people born booted and spurred to write
them that is to say that political
equality in a nation dedicated to the
opposition that all men are created
equal is dependent on the empirical fact
of natural human equality and if you
think about our political history when
Jefferson wrote those words about all
men being created equal in 1776
african-americans and women in fact were
not equal they did not have the right to
political participation and the reason
that they didn't have that right was
that they were believed not to be
basically full human beings they didn't
possess you know sufficient intelligence
or they didn't have the right emotional
characteristics or some other set of
conditions that excluded them from
political participation and one of the
great achievements of 20th century
politics has been to widen that circle
of creatures that have political rights
to encompass basically the entire human
species and that was driven by a
scientific realization that in fact the
variation between genders between ethnic
groups between different human races was
in fact not all that great we are a
relatively homogeneous species now in
theory germline engineering in the long
run will potentially give us the ability
to create people metaphorically born
with saddles on their backs or others
born booted and spurred I think that
many people you know anticipate problems
when you have designer babies you know
the first people that are going to make
use of this technology or elites we're
then going to try to embed their social
advantages genetically in their children
which will then create a class of
enhanced people in a class of unenhanced
people but you could have a much more
you know something that amounts to
almost a speciation where you actually
get genetically different groups of
people musicians you know enhanced
musical ability of their children
athletes and has the athletic ability
and the like and I think that a lot of
people particular a lot of libertarians
look forward to this time when they'll
be able to you know go ahead and you
know turn themselves into cyborgs or you
know or whatnot but I think that they do
not understand the seriousness the
political seriousness of doing something
like this because in fact the nature of
our rights very much you know depends on
our natures and if you undermine that
basic you
principle of the homogeneity of the
species you are going to inevitably
affect the nature of rights themselves
now that's the you know the the
different pathways I the last part of my
book talks about what to do about all of
this and I have a very simple solution
you just regulate biotechnology as a
result I think of the information
technology revolution a lot of people
have tended to think that technology is
unstoppable that first of all it is
illegitimate to try to regulate
technological advance and even if it
were legitimate to do it you can't do it
because you know it'll move to a
different jurisdiction or you'll hold
that progress or what not now I think
that in general we are not talking at
all about stopping technology I don't
think there's any way to stop the
accumulation of scientific knowledge and
I don't think that that is desirable but
it is certainly the case that you can
direct the development of technology
towards aims that are humanly you know
that enhance human flourishing and you
can try to limit the uses of technology
that are a threat to human values we do
this all the time we do this in drug
regulation we do this with regard to
nuclear weapons with regard to toxic
waste with regard to environmental
degradation I mean there are a whole lot
of areas in which things that are
technologically possible to do we were
frame from doing because they do not
promote human values and and and and
human flourishing and I think in the
case of biotechnology you can set up
institutions that will do the same thing
that will promote therapeutic uses of
technology but that will put that as a
priority over let's say the enhancement
uses or other uses that are more
controversial or that raise important
ethical dilemmas I think maybe I will
stop there I can talk a lot more about a
lot of other subjects including you know
whether we're really at the end of
history or whether this is the only
problem with with history being over but
I guess at this point I would like to
invite any comments or questions
thank you
great we will certainly take questions
now and I think many of you know that we
will have people in each of the Isles
volunteers with microphones and I'll
call on you and we would like you to
wait until microphone gets there so that
we can make sure that everybody can hear
the question and we have one person
asking question at a time and I okay
let's go with the person you have right
here and then the hand right here okay
what implications do you see in the
birth rate situation and the groups
coming in from less developed countries
in the difference between the u.s.
approach to integration of these into
our society versus European well the
United States is not going to suffer
from the same kind of falling population
as Europe and Japan will because we have
a higher fertility rate for our
native-born population and then we have
a high rate of immigration and so in
fact I think most estimates show our
population rising over time so the
scenario that faces Europe is not one
that we are going to have but it is
because I think we permit immigration
now I have been in general been a
proponent of immigration but I think
it's not an unproblematic issue because
unless you have assimilation of
culturally different people and a sense
of you know shared citizenship and a
certain minimal set of shared values
then you're going to get you know very
deep conflicts political conflicts
within you know the larger society that
I think even the United States and it's
you know relatively strong political
institutions are going to have trouble
dealing with but I do think that you
know that's you know that's a challenge
that we are much more likely to handle
better than the Germans or the Japanese
or the French or you know other
developed countries yes right here sir
what do you make of Ray Kurzweil's
vision of the future of
the amalgamation of human and computer
technology into a whole new species and
life form well I guess I've never really
been persuaded that you know this
man-machine interface first of all I
think it's a lot further off than then
he would suggest the other thing about
the whole artificial intelligence
community however is that they take this
very reductionist view of the human
brain I mean they say well it's just a
web computer of you know and it's it's
it's a you know maybe now a couple
orders of magnitude more complex than
the most complex machines silicon
machine but when that silicon machine
you know down the road gets up to this
level of complexity then it'll be able
to do everything that a human brain can
do and I just think that you know I
don't know what they're smoking I mean
if they if they think that that's the
case because among other things you know
you have this problem of consciousness
you know human beings are conscious they
have subjective feelings they have
emotions and that somehow emerges out of
this you know complex wet computer we
have they don't have any they don't have
the faintest idea of you know even what
the ontological status of thoughts and
emotions are and no theory whatsoever as
to you know how they evolved over
evolutionary time why they exist in
human beings and this idea that you know
I mean and because they begin with this
very reductionist materialist
understanding of how the brain works
they assume that you know once you build
a complex enough computer bingo you've
got you know a human brain and I just
think that that's you know I mean we
don't even begin to understand you know
how how we complete human beings with
consciousness and emotions and
subjective feelings you know come into
existence and so I don't feel that
there's much of a threat from that
quarter you know coming up okay
interesting yes let's have please raise
your hand we have a person here then
we'll go to the John gentlemen there
will come to this one and then we'll go
back there again
getting calm hope I remember all that
your projections reasonably enough are
based on society as it exists and
projected trends in technology I wonder
if you have considered the situation
which the CDC and the World Health
Organization these are not alarmist
organizations have been agitating about
for a while you remember what happened
with the bubonic plague in the 14th
century and the flipping over of society
as a consequence of that
what would you project is going to be
the outcome of multiple antibiotic
resistance in the society flipping us
into an age of pre-antibiotic disease on
your projections you know I I'm not an
epidemiologist and and I'm not a
scientist you know period so I I can't
really tell you anything meaningful
about that I had a study group in
Washington a while back in which we
invited several speakers on this topic
and a lot of them actually thought that
you know we were going to be able to
keep this under control because the rate
at which these bacteria mutated you know
could could basically be met if there
was simply more investment in new
antibiotics and so that wasn't a race
that we necessarily had to lose but you
know it is a you know it is a you know
one possible scenario but you know I'm
not the right person to ask about that
okay in your lecture you mentioned an
end to if you could stand up it would it
would help all of it would help the two
of us up here should know who's speaking
because of the glare of the lights thank
you very much in your lecture you
mentioned an end to 14 analysis and in
the answer
prior to this last question you
mentioned a certain subjectivity to the
the brain's white computer which
precludes my questioning you about what
went wrong with Colin Ferguson who was
taking selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitors but more focuses my question
now I work with a I work in a
psychiatric hospital I have
particularly adolescent who at 14 years
old has psychotic has a psychotic
dysfunction with manic episodes what as
far as the pathways that you mentioned
which you see not I mean most
immediately I'm sure it's you know just
chemical pharmacological but what of
those pathways which you see as a means
of accessing her unique brand of
intelligence her unique information
processing skillset I mean what do you
see for psychiatric hospitalization in
general specifically that case well I
mean I would assume that a lot of
seriously ill you know people with
people with serious mental disorders
like that you know have been treated
pharmacologically I mean that's what you
know that's what I was referring to with
a decline of Freudian talk therapy that
it turned out that you know Freudians
didn't have anything than a better than
a 50% batting average in in in you know
with regard to therapy whereas a lot of
drugs have been actually quite you know
effective in treating certain forms of
severe you know schizophrenia psychosis
and the like it's not you know a lot of
these diseases are not fully treatable
but at least the biological component of
them has to some degree been been
isolated and therefore is treatable my
suspicion however is that you know human
beings being that kind of complex
interactions of both you know biology
and environment that that there's still
room for the talk therapy as well
because I would think that you know in
addition to you know fixing the you know
the you know the biological substrate
that there's also you know a
psychological layer that that that needs
to be addressed through environment and
you know social interaction and the like
with regard to any specific patient
they're like you know I couldn't tell
you what you know what would be the best
approach okay now we have I wanted to
come down here if we could yes that
you'd bring the microphone down to the
gentleman in the center and then we'll
go back there and then we'll start a new
round I see some more hands up
now you go ahead we'll adjust the
microphone okay I find your argument
about life extension fascinating but
coming to think about it it's not really
about genetic manipulation Europe and
Japan aren't populating themselves
because of normal standard medicine
whether these are medications or other
forms of treatment so maybe your
argument is wider than the way you
presented it here and it is we're
spending too much on life extension
which is as you said individually
beneficial and desirable but socially
might be destructive maybe maybe this is
the complete argument well you know
quite frankly I think that the you know
the the advances in public health that
have occurred up to this point have
already put us in something of a crisis
because you know people are living to
later ages but at you know greater
stages of debility I mean for example if
you you know want to know why there's
been this big explosion of Alzheimer's
it's because it's a degenerative
age-related disease and and you know the
instance of it simply goes up in in
proportion to your you know how old you
are the likelihood that you will get it
and so part of the reason that you have
this this increased incidence of
Alzheimer's is because people are not
dying of heart attacks and cancers and
and other types of diseases and if
you've ever you know spent a lot of time
in a nursing home which I unfortunately
have had to do in the last couple of
years it's it's a very you know it's not
a it's not a pretty picture and so I
think that the you know the overall
effects of of advances in biomedicine
are actually a bit more ambiguous than
then a lot of people assume I mean
anyone any you know people tend to think
anything that can put off disease that
can cure disease that can extend life is
automatically a good thing in and for
many people the value of doing that
trumps you know virtually every any
other kind of consideration and I would
just say that although you know I
certainly don't want to die prematurely
and I would like to be cured of whatever
you know afflictions affect me I'm not
sure that cumulatively that that always
leaves us you know
society better off and I think you're
right that it doesn't have to await
these new technologies I mean to some
extent we're already living with some of
the consequences of past advances in
biomedicine yes please stand so we can
see who's asking the question yeah you
talked about the socialization of the
immigrants coming in and it seems to me
that that's the same issue as the
socialization of kids who are being put
on Ritalin I agree with you totally
inappropriately in many cases so I mean
the question I have is how do we deal
with this issue of everybody's gotta act
exactly the same this is seems to be
ingrained in our society and I wouldn't
I would hesitate to try to make an
answer but maybe you can well look I
think that any society particularly a
pluralistic you know democracy like we
we live in has to be a certain mixture
of community and individualism and our
society tends to tilt very much towards
the individualism side you know we
promote you know difference and
diversity and the like however there are
certain types of diversity that you know
you can't live with politically I mean
the back ends is a wonderfully
ethnically diverse place but it's also
not you know very healthy place you know
to grow up or it's not a very healthy
political community and so I think what
you need is to put diversity within
certain you know limits of shared you
know cultural understandings that permit
people even as they are different both
as individuals or as races or as ethnic
groups you know to share certain common
characteristics now we in the United
States have a big advantage because our
sense of citizenship is a political one
it's not related to blood and soil or to
ethnicity or race or religion and so it
is possible for us to you know have a
set of institutions that we can be loyal
to you know that is indifferent to where
we came from and you know what our our
background is but I do think that you
need to put some limits on that you know
the kind of you know permissible
diversity so that for example I mean
just
make this concrete I think that you know
having the same language is a big you
know is a big advantage and for that
reason I would think that you know
something like bilingualism is is not
helpful in that process of cultural
assimilation and if you can get away
with having a monolingual Society you
really ought to invest in in doing
things like that okay all right now
let's I have some more questions I see
white who I know well cuz he is the
chair of the Friends of the free library
hi Elliot professor I have one question
the the basic assumption you're making
is a fairly optimistic assumption I mean
regulate but I'm aware of Tuskegee I'm
aware of the birth control testing and
third world populations formula testing
and third world populations I'm aware of
in Pennsylvania gas being put in a
tunnel and people driving through
longitudinal studies so there we have
powerful tools for the future but evil
exists amongst us and and so your
question of regulation is is to some
extent simplistic how do you regulate
the military how do you regulate secrecy
and corporations who are not bound by a
set of ethics given the history of these
advances being acted out in third world
population well look no regulatory
system no regulatory system is perfect
and so people will always debate you
know regulation but that doesn't mean
that regulation doesn't work or it's you
know impossible or that you can't you
know take an existing set of regulations
and and enforce them or you know modify
them to make them more you know to make
them more effective and if you don't
believe this
you ought to go to a you know developing
country that does not have a functioning
state and does not have institutions
capable of doing things like drug
regulation or even you know policing you
know streets or in for
some property rights or a lot of other
things that our state actually does
pretty effectively if you want to see
what bad regulation is now in the case I
mean you mentioned the Tuskegee syphilis
case I mean that's an interesting one
because you know we have actually very
strong rules in this country regarding
human experimentation that have gotten
stronger over time I mean despite this
anti-regulatory upsurge of the last
generation wheels on human
experimentation have actually been
tightened up and they were tightened up
precisely in response to things like
Willowbrook you know thalidomide the
Tuskegee syphilis experiment because
people reacted you know in horror - you
know these abuses that had occurred by
simply a kind of unregulated private
market now I think the challenge in
these future bio technologies is you
know to put into place the regulatory
system that will have some effect before
you have a big disaster thing is that
it's always easy you know that the
nuclear power industry now regulates
itself like crazy you know after Three
Mile Island but it didn't see the
necessity of doing that before Three
Mile Island and I think that one of the
big challenge challenges is you know to
be able to anticipate really big
problems before they they happen and
unfortunately if you look at the whole
history of drug regulation I mean you
know the FDA for example I mean the drug
testing you know was driven by this
social Nitta might of elixir a scandal
in which over a hundred children were
poisoned by an unregulated drug back in
the 1930s and unfortunately I mean the
real world experiences that you got to
go through you know a series of these
things until you get you know the right
you know political consensus in favor of
regulation but but I dispute the general
idea that regulation doesn't work I mean
it you know it works in a lot of cases
and it's a question of just designing
the right institutions and to have the
right level of regulation because you
also don't want to hold back you know
valuable things as well I think we have
time for just one more question because
we want to go upstairs and meet dr.
Fukuyama in person and buy his books now
you're making it tough on me I see
hands let's go with the the gentleman
right smack in the center of the one
third of the way back here I'm let's
let's go here and I'll tell you what
well I will go to the net the woman next
to him after that
dr. Fiamma in regards to what you
mentioned that Pepe canons book and if
you agree that his demographic is are
correct but you don't agree with his
ultra Nacional altra nationalist
recommendations or those are someone
like lepen for keeping things as they
are now how would you suggest that with
cultures moving in that are anti Western
or anti modernization how would you
preserve a liberal democracy which you
value so highly without making liberal
democracy itself something that has to
be applied in such a fashion as almost
as if democracy itself becomes a fascist
movement anything else has to be removed
well you know I think you do that
through education I mean you know in in
the early 20th century the public school
system in the United States was used not
just to transmit skills and knowledge it
was also used as you know deliberately I
think to socialize all of these you know
millions of new immigrants that were
coming in from southern Italy or from
you know the former Czarist Empire you
know different parts of Europe China and
so forth and Americanizing them and I
think one of the big problems in the
United States now is with the rise of
things like multiculturalism and
bilingualism instead of you know being
kind of self confident about American
values and and you know and try to
socialize people you know regardless of
race and national origin you know to
that set of standards we now celebrate
you know everybody's remaining
culturally different which i think is
not you know but I think that you can
only have a successful immigration
policy if you also try to you know to
assimilate people I don't think it has
to be done with fascist methods I think
you know you say very clearly you you
know you you revive things like civics
you know and
teach people about basic political
values and you know I think that's the
way that you you do that and and the
country I think is sufficiently
attractive as a society that you don't
have to hit people over the head with
that I really do think that you can do
it in a much more you know kind of
appealing and you know attractive
fashion okay in our last and our last
question please I just wonder if you
would address the stem cell issue
especially since so many Nobel Prize
scientist Prize winners have addressed
it and endorsed it I you know was in
favor of stem-cell research under the
guidelines that the NIH had had set up
which was that you know they in in
deference to I mean I'm not pro-life
personally but I think that it's
reasonable in in a country where you got
a substantial number of people that feel
very strongly about that that it was
quite reasonable that you would permit
stem-cell research under certain
conditions that they'd be you know taken
from leftover embryos from IVF clinics
and was you know informed consent and so
on and so forth well I think the problem
and so I was quite happy you know with
with those rules and President Bush's
decision by the way I'm speaking just on
my own behalf I'm not speaking I mean I
am a member of his bioethics Council but
the council has a lot of diverse views
and I'm not speaking in in their name
I think his decision was a little bit
more restrictive than I would have
preferred but I thought it was you know
a reasonable position to take the more
difficult one is is the cloning
legislation that's currently before the
Congress which seeks to ban both
reproductive cloning that is to say
cloning to produce a child and in one
version would also ban so-called
therapeutic or research cloning now my
position I have supported the broader
ban for a very specific reason which is
that I do think that it is a big step to
take to deliberately create a cloned
embryo only for research purposes that I
do not believe that an embryo has the
moral status of an infant but it is
definitely something very human and it's
a line that we oughta cross I think very
cautiously and while people would be
willing to extract stem cells from
embryos I'm not so sure that you know
they would how they'd feel about you
know five years from now if you decided
you had to extract entire organs or
tissues from a fetus you know that was
three or four months old grown
deliberately you know for that purpose
and so I am you know a little bit
worried about the precedents that we're
setting in doing this and so actually my
own preference is that if we permit the
so called therapeutic cloning to go
ahead that it be encased in a lot of in
our inner regulatory system that will
prevent us from sliding down that
particular slippery slope well thank you
please please join us upstairs there's
cookies and coffee and of course books
and our special guests to say hello to
personally
Francis Fukuyama is the author of the
end of history and the last man trust
and the great disruption as latest our
posthuman future is published by ferric
Straus and Giroux online at FSG books
calm